Et bien bonjour chers amis, comment-allez-vous?
Nous ça va extrêmement bien.
C'est là la caméra?
Oui celle la
C'est trop bizarre qu'elle soit là-bas
Ouais, parce qu'elle est pas droite, ouais.
Les amis nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
Car il y a pas longtemps nous sommes aller à Londres
pour une conférence HONOR
HONOR le super téléphone!
Non, la vidéo là elle est pas sponsorisé.
Ah ok ok!
Il est quand même bien, il est quand même sympa.
Et on est passé devant un magasin de jouet qui s'appelle "Hamleys".
C'est un magasin de jouets pour enfants sur 6 étages, c'était génial ce moment dans ce magasin.
SEB: c'était super
On a eu une idée de concept
à chacun sa petite ardoise
Voilà
Aujourd'hui nous allons à tour de rôle présenter un jouet
mmh mmh
Tu fumes? En pleine vidéo?
Ouais.
C'est interdit ici frérot.
Oui, éteins.
Le but c'est de présenter les meilleurs jouets et d'avoir les meilleurs notes tout simplement .
A la fin de la vidéo on feras la moyenne de toutes les notes de chacun, celui qui auras la meilleur note a gagné la vidéo.
Mais c'est pas tout, on invitera les gens à voter sur un sondage Twitter, sur mon compte Twitter.
On a envie de savoir qui a gagné selon les gens, n'est-ce pas?
*son de craie*  aah
N'oublis pas, il faut qu'on ai envie d'acheter ton jouet à la fin.
Donc c'est un jouet qui nécessite un petit peu de préparation.
Avant de vous le présenter dans sa globalité
je vais vous demander de vous occuper en dessinant par exemple
Euuh .. des étoiles
Bon...
Ooh très jolies!
tu noterait la quelle?
Deux styles différents.
Tu préfères lequel ?
Moi j'aime beaucoup celui de Lucas, on dirait le carré du drapeau de l'Amérique.
Tandis que j'adore aussi celui de Max...
Il veut pas nous fâcher, il sait qu'on le note.
Seb, on te regarde.
Bon, qui n'a jamais rêvé d'être un Jedi?
Personnellement, j'adore Star Wars et il y a quelque chose dans Star Wars qui m'a beaucoup plus.
C'est le concept de force.
Je crois qu'il s'allume...
Ouiiii ! Aaaah !
Bravo ! Bravo !
Je suis en plein combat Jedi.
Tac tac ! Ah !
Je tombe au sol.
Le sabre est loin de toi.
Le sabre est un peu loin de moi. Je vais pas le mettre loin parce que ce sera pas dans le cadre
Mais là t'as besoin de la force pour la...
Mais t'as carrément pas besoin de la force pour le prendre.
Si, si regarde
En fait en utilisant la force
*WOUAH*
Et là je remonte
TAC *rire de lucas*
Tu peux faire...
*rire*
Et là pourquoi t'as pas utiliser la force là?
Attends, attends!
Oh c'est stylé
Oh bien bien
*rire*
Mais la force ça se maîtrise tu vois
Ok
C'est des choses où, bon voilà, c'est un peu nouveau pour moi.
Il est maintenant temps chers amis de noter cette prestation
Sur 20?
Plus t'as envie de l'acheter, plus tu mets une bonne note, voilà.
J'ai pas été super convaincant mais sachez que c'est qu'une question de temps
Il vient de gagner un point.
J'ai pas eu assez de temps pour bien maîtriser l'objet.
*musique*
En vrai, ça va.
On a beaucoup aimés ton investissement dans la présentation de cet objet.
Et c'est pas encombrant.
*rire*
Messieurs, dames.
SEB: Oui
Bravo pour votre prestation monsieur Frit.
Merci.
C'était très sympa.
Je suis moi même un grand adepte de la force. Qui n'a jamais rêvé de voir un UFO dans le ciel?
Vous en avez déjà vu?
J'ai vécu une expérience UFO.
MAXENSS: C'est vrai? SEB: Ouais.
T'as vu quoi?
J'étais sur une plage, euh... vers le bassin d'Arcachon
Je peux présenter mon jouet?
Ah pardon!
Ceci est un UFO, et il vole. Grâce à la force.
Ça veut dire quoi UFO?
MAXENSS: Ok
Ah là pour le coup on sait ce que c'est, c'est pas un UFO du coup.
C'est un truc en aluminium.
Attends, Attends mais tu dis que son...
Ah oui pardon.
Laisse. Vas-y!
Je vais pouvoir faire voler cet UFO, tel monsieur Frit a attiré son sabre dans sa main.
D'accord.
Vous voyez cette soucoupe volante?
Elle vole, c'est bon? Je peux la faire voler autour de moi, sans aucun problème.
SEB: Ok, c'était... oui.
Donc cette soucoupe, hop, elle peut voler de cette manière.
SEB: C'est stylé! SQUEEZIE: N'est-ce pas? Et je la récupère.
Il sert à quoi le fil qui pends?
Non non y a pas de fil.
Regarde, y a aucun fil.
Vous pouvez refaire?
La refaire voler? SEB: Oui. SQUEEZIE: Bien sûr. Je la refais voler.
T'as un bouton euh...
Ah pu**** ouais, c'est ce matin mec en me réveillant il me faisait mal déjà.
SEB: Yes
Moi 14.
Alors 14 dans le sens où si mon sabre laser très similaire est à 13, l'UFO a au moins l'audace de tourner, et d'être un peu plus esthétique que...
ah, et ben les gars je m'en sort avec un petit 11,5 de moyenne
pour le moment c'est pas trop dégeu
ça va
alors on continu
j'ai besoin d' un peu de preparation
ok ok
*rire* ça va max
ouais tranquille
max on t'entend
oui je sais
allez vient on t'écoute